all right we're bringing sexy back we're
bringing sexy back Dean at that was good
being stopped by fans we can find it
right we could find it we don't ask do
any dance we already believe nation
[Music]
hello believe nation its day six how's
Nina doing I slept very poorly very poor
it
yeah you too you were woody yeah yeah I
only got a couple hours sleep I don't
know if it's the allergies or or just
the amount of food that I ate before
going to bed or what but anyway we're
looking about a good day
we're in Oslo haven't landed yet but
we're about to we get in an 8 a.m. leave
at 8 p.m. so we got a full day here
ready to enjoy Nina's excited it is cold
boot ten degrees high I don't know what
that is in Fahrenheit but it means cold
and it's gonna rain so we'll do our best
to get around and see the city but it
never been Oslo open in Norway so I'm
pumped to be here we'll take you with us
but first you breakfast
this is round one for me and there's
round one for Nina all right round two
we got Froot Loops and we've got yogurt
could end mole saw the breakfast was
good
Lena's feeling full you finally got the
boat explore something Norway it's
raining it's raining in Oslo first task
is look at how cute in a hoodie second
ties it's trying to find an umbrella see
how we do so we decided to get a hop-on
hop-off bus so it's easy to get around
the rain get a free guided tour and well
something up a couple ponchos in case we
decide to get out leave this and look
pretty cute here poncho
It's Made in China see Nina was made in
China too but it's to be proud
[Music]
we got our Poncho's ready like stop his
arse
all right we're bringing sexy back
we're bringing sexy back Nina let's go
hit up some Oslo this reminds me of Lena
which she hasn't had her coffee I feel
like we should get you a coffee
let's find our Starbucks
[Music]
[Music]
founder Starbucks we're getting some
venti caramel macchiato so warm up could
do the cappuccino good cold tea gonna
chill in the Starbucks area back there
and enjoy our drinks
[Music]
let me show you guys this view this is
inside the train station here at Oslo
Starbucks is on the balcony it's pretty
cool so we got stopped by Kyle fan of
the channel Chi ka I you have a business
working on it what's your favorite video
[Music]
nice I love it
kai in Norway that was good being
stopped by fans this time we didn't say
hey Nina
you know Nina got stopped on our a
couple days ago in London by a fan
members named Jacob come on Nina you got
stopped by your friend younger chicken
what's up Jacob next time stop me okay I
would I remember you because he must be
watching a lot of your videos to
recognize me
so okay I mean it doesn't even remember
your name Jacob okay next time to me I
know it's always fun being stopped by
fans cool guy Kai he's just off to work
I told me needs to set his business he
hasn't started it yet like hey you're
watching all these videos you got to
take some action so Kai start your
business I want to see it alright
Starbucks was good relaxing
three there for like 40 minutes 45
minutes got to dry off and now we're
gonna head out to the main city center
hopefully make it to the grand old cafe
which is the cafe apparently in Oslo but
it's raining outside so we'll see how
high we get Nina's not feeling the rain
if it's too rainy we might head back to
the cruise ship we'll play it by ear
let's see how far we get fingers crossed
I can't I can't cross right there we go
fingers crossed all right we've got two
local beers are eagerly alright three
green and this one I think it's building
just add Ignis so both blonde light
beers give both a try Nina let's see
you're the taste tester what do you got
not not not that impressed once a
pilsner winds up white beer and
yeah it looks stronger but which one you
like better neither am i having two
beers tonight for lunch okay got a
choice new stuff starting up grilled
mackerel with dill sauce and potato
chips inside is it raw forget
[Music]
cured how was it different well I like
it
probably not I don't know I'll have the
chip
alright good start it start so I got the
hate which is a white fish that's buried
under there is cabbage and fish eggs on
top it mean that it got lamb with
asparagus peas big leak a leak that's
what that is
okay so Tiger lemon apparently Norway is
known for its lamb this is one of the
recommended things to eat so here she
goes that looks really tender
[Music]
yeah thumbs up
yes the lime is good try the hake you're
like making a little tortilla they're
baked tortilla all right nice all right
winner winner in Oslo dessert is here
apple compote with cinnamon ice cream
Annina
another
okay you can do the taster we get new
food for you
and how many bites you need to have
before you know it hurt although yeah
how about the apple compote
all right it's into an ice cream holy
cow it's all garden look how much it's
quality meal we've got our sexy reindeer
back on and we're gonna see if we can
find the ice bar that is hopefully close
fine
I know we can find it right we could
find it we don't need to ask do any pass
[Music]
we just were some rain punches and now
we get to wear some ice ponchos
what's up Nina look at that magic ice
poncho looking good
we already believe nation ready for our
ice tour let's do it let's get our
drinks oh it's cold
push the door Nina there we go
oh it's ice that's legit I see your
breath you can frost wine that's what
you get
[Music]
Cheers
that was it oh my god it's ice the cup
is ice oh my god it's a glass but then
they have ice on top of the class that
you're drinking from oh this could be
our new look you know what do you think
lock your hands beats of Toronto get
some belief parkas happening feeling
this my feet stick to the floor here for
some reason maybe it's because they have
water underneath are your feet sticking
no you don't feel it this is what we're
drinking rice wine it's good oh this is
a unique experience I'm glad we came huh
that we came
[Music]
let's stop only Nina where you going
what let's stop only there's a curtain
here for a reason
cuz it's forced on you exit the way we
came in yeah that's it okay let's get
warm oh let's get warm all right that
was good sometimes
[Music]
all right so
we don't want to be in the rain anymore
we're gonna go back to the cruise
apparently hey pop quiz Xena remember
the guy we met at Starbucks what's his
name okay Kai that's right
Kai said I thought jokingly that there's
only 20 days of sunshine a year in Oslo
but it's raining all day and if you look
at the forecast for the next two weeks
it's raining all day every day
I feel bad yeah I guess you get used to
just rain all the time so anyway we're
gonna head back to the boat take your
vitamin B such a b b d oh that's a sun
vitamin yeah
kai likes to get to California every
year
so you get some Sun and again I thought
he was joking but I get it now I
understand anyway it's sliding it's like
it's letting up a little bit but still
just gloomy so we're gonna back to the
boat and then
work out relax eat
yeah another great day all right let's
do it
[Music]
[Music]
all right so we relaxed we chilled we
changed you gonna put her wet shoes back
on mine too so and now we're gonna go
work out and then we can eat - feel like
if I do at least ten push-ups I'll get
to be the control of ice cream it's how
it works right that's how it works
let's do it all right next up at least
300 calories I'm a treadmill while I
answer your questions on social media I
love it let's go going at a speed a
four-point over that 8.5 incline there
we go we did my 300 calories that was a
burn it was Austin I got some crazy
sweat happening up here look Nina's
still going Nina's going for an hour
she's hardcore listen though look look
at this one thing I love about these
guys here you can get these cold towels
they're freezing and when you're done
your workout that feels good hmm I got a
petition my condo to get a little towel
machine here and get used to death all
right I'm gonna do why I don't gonna do
do some work while I wait for you to
finish up maybe answer some more your
questions would Annina get the ELISA
Doku how was your workout how many
calories for 50 nice and 500 I did 300
Nina's a rock star let's see a flex
oh pretty good okay Nina
playing there water drink drink like an
alcoholic drink oh wow okay go back down
for what
Oh like we're gonna be on a snack right
now oh and then shower and then go for
dinner
no all right I could I was just that
snack shower dinner
yeah remember at the snack Nina it snack
I'm just gonna get a copy as a snack I
don't wanna fill up too much before
dinner
what do you get Nina fried rice curry
noodle
nice try the carrillo streets about that
good all right Nina's getting her drink
what do you get Nina
all right Nina Cheers I feel like this
is a great idea that's a stupid idea
[Music]
okay let me read something what why are
you drinking it that's my coffee how is
it it's pretty good eggs and come on
guys you know this looks great
Oh alrighty there's Nina
we had our shower I feel good after the
shower you feel relaxed we're gonna go
eat dinner it's early say 5:30 dinner
opens at 5:00 we're gonna get there
Wallace 5:30 but I'm hungry I'm hungry
give me some food
we're gonna see what's there we're gonna
eat a lot Nina's gonna get some drinks
and we're gonna plan for what we're
gonna do tonight as well as what we're
gonna do tomorrow we head to Copenhagen
alright just finished our meal
Nina's feeling well
and so we're gonna do what we always do
after our huge meals check out the
dessert go up to the buffet and look at
the desserts it should be surprised by
this point this is what we tend to do
now after every meal I have a massive
meal then look at the desserts I'm
hoping for some apple cobbler with maybe
some ice cream on top and caramel sauce
Nina's hoping for drink more alcohol
oh my god alcohol has less calorie dense
ice cream believe me she means to
fact-check that fact check calories of
ice cream versus why well let's see what
the dessert is I'm excited your new
Italian wine have a shot how's it taste
Nina both veloute
[Music]
you sit all right I'm pretty sure this
is it
sherry and pineapple cobbler with
caramel sauce as long as this caramel
size we are good to go go to some
vanilla ice cream on top of that yeah
baby
extra dessert time look at this
awesomeness guys not just imagine it
with a ton of vanilla ice cream on top
yeah struggling holy cow
excuses look at the ice cream no do you
want me to help you let me show you how
to get ice cream yeah but you're putting
in a cone that's cheating it's so easy
to put anybody can put ice cream in the
cone you put it in a tiny bowl like that
it's so you try putting it on top of
[Music]
listen I warmed up the machine for you
then you have to pull free hands you got
to do in paper either your arm and now
watering food in front of you that's
just so that's just so basic that's
that's okay that's what everybody does
this is does not look like white poo it
looks like a work of art okay this is a
work of art okay you just did you just
did what everybody else does okay boring
standard ice cream this oh you can't get
that anywhere
that's the Evan Carmichael original
creation holy that's a little too much
caramel sauce okay let's go eat Nina's
fun to have fun one right Nina Nina Nina
likes it good
okay I would poke you right now but I
don't have a hand oh she's having paid
attention oh look at the caramel in the
hair just finished eating Bill Gross too
much
I'm just both mothers
how do you finish manga Nina's coming
back for food later maybe I'll feel
better than in house too much pizza
snacks will see us eat less
[Music]
what did you get - Jen Tina which is
good what is it
Pilsner Urquell alright I like pilsners
but I'm full we're gonna go to the room
and relax I feel like you need to
clarify - what I mean by relaxed because
I'm gonna go to the room and work on my
blog that's how I relax I'm gonna go and
work on the book cuz I gotta make
something awesome for you guys so we're
gonna sit on the bed we're gonna put on
BBC because they don't have CNN here and
I'm gonna work on my buck and that's my
relaxation because that's awesome
[Music]
making some really really really really
good progress in the book I will have
most of it done by the time I get back a
few minor tweaks to make on my computer
and then I'm going to be pretty much
ready to give it to my test audience to
get feedback from I am so super excited
for this and really pumped to see what
the impact is gonna be I'm excited so
that's it for me today thank you guys
for joining another day here in Oslo it
is what 10 10 10 15 right now I'm gonna
do a little bit more work on the book
get some more stuff done what are you
doing
Lena's in bed I wanted to Nina fell
asleep and woke up deeper massage
nice to you give you a nice massage holy
cow
amazing massage magic hands right here
thank you guys so much for watching
tomorrow we will be in Copenhagen that
would be next week's video guess for you
guys so believe guys and whatever you
want or else we'll see you soon
much love